am dienstag besucht
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
die blackrock staffel in langen leben
dabei freut sie sich den bereits dritten
modernisierten blackrock helikopter für
den einsatz übergeben zu können
es ist eine grosse
modernisierungsoffensive die wir nicht
nur
hock vorzunehmen haben sondern die das
gesamte österreichische bundesheer
betreten als beispiel nennt anna unter
anderem den waldbrand auf der rax
vergangenes jahr ohne eine moderne
luftflotte seien einsätze wie diese so
nicht durchführbar große erwartungen
setzt die verteidigungsministerin schon
jetzt in dem noch nicht ausgeliefert
nachfolger der all whites drei den
leonardo a w 169
dass gerade auch unser neues fluggerät
der leonardo auch einen sehr großen
beitrag leisten wird
[Musik]